foreign
[Music]
Joyce is a dick to the school
Landscaping crew don't Screech to a halt
in the grass do you have any idea how
hard it is to cover up tracks and soil
and replant the grass takes weeks to
undo Screech on the pavement like
everyone else I think it's having
another episode as long as it's not an
episode where 11 goes off with some
other kids with powers in a van for an
hour I'm so glad that never happens
will will Venom Let There Be will buyers
possession indwelling Dominion
excitement okay that totally freaked me
out I understand why we're freaked the
audience all will get possessed Max just
saw a boy standing in the football field
with his eyes closed why is she freaked
out that was me every day during
marching band practice for four years of
high school nobody else got freaked out
I mean the bullying freaked me out a
little but that's entirely unrelated
mostly two episodes in two days it's
getting worse kids that aren't medical
professionals who think they are medical
professionals or just kids you think
it's true sight that would make sense
though since Advanced Dungeons and
Dragons is the addition out when the
season takes place the spelled true
sight which is called true seeing is
only available to clerics in the show
already established that will plays a
wizard yeah I do feel really cool right
now thanks for asking these episodes
that you're having I think Dr Owens is
wrong moms that aren't medical
professionals that think they are
medical professionals or just moms I
tried
[Music]
screamed go away once I feel like you're
overselling your attempts here will you
call me
what does that mean I felt it
everywhere puberty I will never ever let
anything bad happen to you ever again
wow that's a big talk for the mom of an
eternal victim when the series still has
three more seasons to go I'm sure she'll
keep that promise though hey
what the hell is wrong with you I don't
know how maybe a grown man she looked up
to as a father figure has been screaming
at her for the last five minutes
forgetting that this is a child with
severe PTSD what you can spot it in will
but not your own kid you know what
here's five sins for being an absolute
head you're gonna have a girls night
romantic comedies do our nails gossip
damn it Nancy rule one of lying keep it
simple don't say one word more than you
need to a girl's night at Stacy's was
perfectly fine they all know what a
girl's night means and I also know what
a girl's night means because of this
book I'm reading which is also
coincidentally called a girls night at
Stacy's
tell him to call me the second he gets
in please if Opera thought Joyce was
going to need him in an emergency why
not just get her a radio he uses one to
communicate with L when he's not yelling
at her buy her one for emergencies
because cell phones don't exist yet I'm
also thinking Hopper is an inning way
qualified to assist your child with
mental health issues I think he's more
than proven otherwise during the
previous 10 minutes you promised no
doctor you have a sick child and you
promise not to take him to the one
qualified health expert that can help
jeez Joyce oh I know take him to a nurse
practitioner they can prescribe
medication if need be and they're
technically non-doctors what all our
YouTube channels have sin in the name
you didn't expect we'd have demons on
staff to write out complex agreements
and tricky word qualifiers how do you
think we can snare our sin club members
speaking of which if you haven't already
I'm gonna run you an ice bath and it'll
warm you up forcing your kid to soak in
their own filth morning Dart meanwhile
on Dustin and dart which would easily be
the least interesting subplot this show
has ever had if it wasn't for that 11
joins the X-Men episode but it still
sucks it's too hot you're not five will
you know where the cold water knob is
use it
[Applause]
promoting flopping also Steve was the
star of the basketball team before Billy
came to town he should already [__]
know that and now this show is making me
think about joining team billion I don't
like it plenty of [__] in the sea in
microplastics plenty of those in the sea
too okay
there what he's just talk to himself
being so bad at your surveillance job
that a couple of teenagers spotted you
rookie mistake you two you had one
getaway option and you parked it out in
the open did you do watch any of the
Bond films there's like 13 by this point
in the show damn Will's a great artist
does anyone know if he's taking
commissions for d d character portraits
because I've got this tivling warlock
who wanders water deep and
Aaron you're doing it again focus on the
script stop being such a dork I'm not a
dork you're a dork
I mean roll d20s well didn't want me to
tell anyone but Mike is betraying Will's
trust because if this Series has taught
me anything it's that Mike is a terrible
friend withholding valuable information
when your friend's life is at stake holy
sh did hop really leave a child in the
cabin full of broken glass maybe Elle
would be safer in a lab with Papa I'm
sorry but these boxes are way too clean
to spend all the time below a Dusty
Cabin in the Woods of rural Indiana have
you ever been to Butler Indiana it's
kind of like Hawkins seen some basements
there and let me tell you things stored
down there don't stay clean very long
sorry about that hospitality is not our
strong suit was he outside the door
until Nancy screamed at the camera or
was that a coincidence either way
convenient timing is convenient also his
Hospitality ever been the strong suit of
an evil lab I've seen a lot of evil Labs
from mandark's workspace to the Death
Star and let me tell you not one of them
served cookies men of science have made
abundant mistakes of every kind well
that's not the full quote doc certain
goes on to say their knowledge has
improved only because of their gradual
abandonment of ancient errors poor
approximations and premature conclusions
you had all the data from season one to
abandon ancient era's poor
approximations in premature conclusions
all that information to tell you to stop
[__] with the upside down but you
kept doing it so maybe find another
scientist to quote what if they tried to
replicate that I don't think you're
defensive what if the Russians knew we
[__] with the physics of time and
space is as effective as you imagine it
to be between this and the TV stand at
the cabin Hopper clearly refuses to take
heavy items off heavier objects before
moving them so I guess the sin is
Hoppers back surviving this this is all
blue and this weird dirt color you mean
Brown also there's black on those
drawings and purple Joyce is terrible at
color theory he's drawing fines Hopper
thinking that was all he needed to say
to his good friend who's freaking the
[__] out and worried to death about her
son before he abruptly leaves
[Music]
creating a super intense moment in the
score for Hopper carrying a shovel never
knew digging could be so intense
Tarzan also looks like 11 was lucky
enough to find the expositional dump
file I was trying to remember where I
put that you'd think by now 11 would
learn to bring better shoes for upside
down World water walks sliders are your
friend now I understand the car wasn't
starting earlier but did Jonathan and
Nancy really think it wouldn't start now
after creepy surveillance guy gave
Jonathan the keys and wished them both a
good day I mean it had to get to their
location somehow if you're telling me
the government agency that can tap
Nancy's phone didn't think to check her
purse for a recording device that's some
[__] that only exists because the
writers needed the bad guys to make a
mistake come on Duffer Brothers you're
better than this I think
not particularly Jonathan but Jeremy
told me that if I didn't keep going he'd
lock me in the shed with the Badgers
again so my hands are tied just as they
would be in the shed
gotta talk to you buddy leaving the
lights on when you're not in the room
until you run up your parents power bill
Dustin what's next you gonna open your
window in these to use on so your family
can pay the air conditioning for the
whole neighborhood did Dustin's mother
not hear the glass shatter on this tank
and come to investigate having a hard
time believing dart's violent Escape
went unnoticed so not only did Dustin's
mother inexplicably fail to hear
shattering glass but she somehow missed
the cat being murdered as well have you
heard cats when they think they're dying
those are some loud [__] I'm not
buying Dustin's mom somehow missing all
of this episode expects us to believe
that a man whose daily diet includes a
hearty helping of donuts cigarettes and
beer could dig a hole this large all on
his own in just a few hours and I do not
believe you episode
what exactly was Hopper hanging on to to
lower himself down into this hole you
know what Duffer Brothers You've maxed
out the unbelievability credit card so
there's 10 more sins shot him down Sonny
he won't say to cats
you are mine I just want this to be over
it's okay there's a new sheriff in town
will didn't want me to tell anyone but
on Halloween night he saw a sort of
shadow in the sky
a shadow what kind of Shadow
six-year-old child with this blang pale
emotionless face and the blackest eyes
the devil's eyes
this means
God
reduced the atoms